marine le pen has perhaps never been as
close to power the latest polls indicate
the leader of france's far-right
national party still wants to curb
immigration and ban muslim headscarves
in public places
but she's focused her campaign on the
cost of living crisis it's the number
one issue for french voters ahead of the
war in ukraine the environment and
health
she is better than macron in every
aspect security the future for the youth
purchasing power everything
and she loves france not only europe
many people who voted macron last time
will vote le pen now because he did far
from great and what he proposes now is
even worse than five years ago
le pen's team is worried about voter
apathy a low turnout in regional
elections last june led to disappointing
results for her party
[Music]
i beg you to go and vote there is no win
unless you go and vote to those who have
given up on this citizen's gesture
because of your anger your disgust
disillusion or tiredness i tell them i
understand you
but right now get back into your role of
citizen in the presidential election you
can't abstain take back control
[Music]
polls have long predicted a victory for
incumbent president emmanuel macron his
team is worried about support as being
complacent
macron beat le pen by a margin of 30
percent when they faced off in the
presidential election five years ago
this has been a polished campaign back
in 2017 many voters felt that marine le
pen wasn't presidential her team has
been working hard on her image and it
seems to be paying off the latest polls
have the race between her and president
emmanuel macron narrowing
le pen heads into sunday's first round
election with a predicted 22 to 24 share
of the vote against macron's 26 percent
and 39 of french people consider she has
the stature of a president that's up
from 21
in 2017.
her team hope that suggests france is in
for a real political shock
bernard smith al jazeera perpignan